The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons License.
Additional information
about our license,
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general,
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, where am I
with this problem?
Well, last time I spoke about
what the situation's like
as alpha goes to infinity.
And I want to say also a word
about -- more than a word --
about alpha going to 0.
And then, the real problems
come when alpha is in between.
The real problem
-- the situations,
these ill-posed problems that
come from inverse problems,
trying to find out what's
inside your brain by taking
measurements at the skull.
All sorts of applications
involve a finite alpha.
And I'm not quite ready
to discuss those topics.
I mean, roughly speaking --
I'll write down a reminder now.
What happened when
alpha went to infinity?
When alpha went to
infinity, this part
became the important part.
So as alpha went to infinity,
the limit was u_infinity,
shall I call it? u_infinity.
Well, so u_infinity was
a minimizer of this term,
u_infinity minimized
B*u minus d squared.
In fact, in my last lecture,
I was taking B*u equal d
as an equation that
had exact solutions,
and saying how did we
actually solve B*u equal d.
So u_infinity
minimizes B*u minus d.
But that might
leave some freedom.
If B doesn't have
that many rows,
if its rank is not
that big, then this
doesn't finish the job.
So among these, if
there are many --
and that's what were
interested in --
u hat infinity, that limit,
will minimize the other bit,
A*u minus b square.
Does that makes sense somehow?
This is in the problem
here, for any finite alpha.
As alpha gets bigger
and bigger, we
push harder and
harder on this one,
so we get a one that's
a winner for this one,
but the trace of this
first part is still around
and if there are many winners,
then having this first part
in there will give us, among
the winners, the one that
does the best on that term.
And small alpha,
going to 0, will just
be the opposite right?
This finally struck
me over the weekend,
you know, like I could
divide this quantity,
this whole expression by
alpha, so then I have a 1
there, and a 1 over alpha
here, and now as alpha
goes 0 this is the big term.
So now u -- shall
I call this u_0?
Brilliant notation, right?
So this produces a u_alpha.
In that limit it converges to
a u_infinity that focuses first
on this problem, but
in the other limit,
when alpha's going to 0, it's
this term that's biggest.
So u_0 minimizes A*u minus b
squared and if there are many
minimizers, among these --
well, you know what I'm going
to write. u_0, see I
put a little hat there.
Did I?
I don't know I haven't
stayed with these hats
very much but maybe
I'll add them.
u hat minimizes the term
that's not so important,
B*u minus d square.
OK, so today's lecture is still
about these limiting cases.
As I said, the scientific
problems, ill-posed problems,
especially these
inverse problems,
give situations in which
these limiting problems are
really bad, and you don't get
to the limit, you don't want to.
The whole point is to
have a finite alpha.
But choosing that alpha
correctly is the art --
let me just say
why -- so I almost,
I'm sort of anticipating what
I'm not ready to do properly.
So, I'll say why a finite
alpha, on Wednesday.
Why?
Because noisy data.
Because of the noise, at
best u is only determined,
because of the noise,
up to some order,
say, order of some
small quantity
delta that measures the noise.
This is like a
measure of the noise.
Then there's no reason to
do what we did last time,
like forcing B*u equal d.
There's no point in forcing
B*u equal d if the d in that
equation has noise in it,
then pushing it all the way
to the limit is unreasonable,
and may produce a very,
you know, a
catastrophic illness.
So that's when -- so it's
really the presence of noise,
the presence of uncertainty in
the first place that says OK,
a finite alpha is fine, you're
not looking for perfection,
what you're looking
for is some stability,
some control on the stability.
OK, right.
But now -- so that's Wednesday.
Today, let me go -- I didn't
give an example, so today,
two topics, one is an
example with B*u equal d.
That was last
lecture's, and that's
the case when alpha
goes to infinity,
then secondly is something
called a pseudoinverse.
You may have seen that
expression, the pseudoinverse
of A, and sometimes it's
written A with a dagger or A
with a plus sign.
And that is worth knowing about.
So this is a topic
in linear algebra.
It would be in my
linear algebra book,
but it's a topic that never
gets into the 18.06 course cause
it's sort of a little late.
And that will appear
as alpha goes to 0.
Right.
So that's what
today is about, it's
linear algebra, because I'm
not ready for the noise yet.
But it's the noisy data
that we have in reality
and that's why, in reality,
alpha will be chosen finite.
OK.
So part one, then, is to do a
very simple example with B*u
equal d.
And here is the example.
OK.
So this is my sum of
squares in which I plan
to let alpha to go to infinity.
So A is the identity
matrix and b is 0.
So that quantity is simple.
Here, I have just one equation,
so p is 1; p by n is 1 by 2.
I've just one equation u_1 minus
u_2 equals 6, and in the limit,
as alpha go to
infinity, I expect
to see that that
equation is enforced.
So there's two ways to do it,
we can let alpha go to infinity
and look at u_alpha
going toward u_infinity,
maybe with their little hats.
Or the second method which is
the null space method, which is
what I spoke about last time.
the null space method solves the
constraint B*u equal d which is
just u_1 minus u_2 equal 6.
OK.
And that's -- maybe I'll
start with that one.
Which looks so simple,
of course, just
to solve u_1 minus u_2 equal 6.
I mean, everybody
would say, OK, solve it
for u_2 equals u_1 minus 6.
So here is the method any
sensible person would use.
But this course doesn't.
OK, the sensible method
would be u_2 is u_1 minus 6;
plug that into the
squares and minimize.
So when I plug this in,
of course, this is exact,
and this becomes u
-- so I'm minimizing,
minimizing u_1 squared
plus, what was it?
u_1 minus 6 square.
So that's reduced the
problem to one unknown,
this is the null space method.
The null space method
is to solve the equation
and remove unknowns.
Remove p unknowns coming
from the p constraints,
and here p is 1.
OK.
And by the way, can we
just guess, or not guess,
but pretty well be sure,
what's the minimizer here?
Anybody just tell me what
u_1 would minimize that?
Just make a guess, maybe?
I'm looking for a number sort
of halfway between 0 and 6
somehow.
You won't be surprised
that the u_1 is 3.
And then, from this equation, I
should learn that u_2 is minus
3 -- u_2, no, u_(2, infinity).
Now I've got too many --
u_(2, infinity) is minus 3.
Anyway, simple calculus, if you
just set the derivative to 0,
you'll get 3 and then
you get minus 3 for u_2.
So that's the null space
method, except that I
didn't follow my complicated
QR orthogonalization.
And I just want
to do that quickly
to reach the same answer.
And to say, why don't
I just do this anyway?
This is what -- this
would be the row --
this would be the standard
method in the first month
of linear algebra would be to
use the row reduced echelon
form, which of course
is going to be really,
really simple for
this matrix; in fact,
that's already in row reduced
echelon form -- elimination,
row reduction has nothing
to do to improve that --
and then solve and then
plug in and then go with it.
OK, well the thing
is that that row
reduced echelon form, the
stuff you teach, is not,
for large systems,
guaranteed stable.
It's not numerically stable.
And the option of using--
of orthogonalizing
is the right one to
know for a large system.
So you you'll have to allow me,
on this really small example,
to use a method that
I described last time.
And I just want to recap with
an example on the small system.
OK, so what was that method?
So this is the null space
method using qr now.
The MATLAB command qr, so
what did we -- qr of B prime.
Do you remember
that we took that --
that's the MATLAB command
that eventually will,
or is actually already in
the notes for this section,
and those notes
will get updated --
but that's step one in
the null space method,
qr B prime.
And this gives me a
chance to say what's
up with this qr algorithm.
I mean after lu, qr is the most
important algorithm in MATLAB.
And so what does it do?
B prime, the transpose of B,
is just 1, minus 1, right?
OK.
Now what does Gram-Schmidt
do to that matrix?
Well, the idea of
Gram-Schmidt is
to produce orthonormal columns.
So the most basic Gram-Schmidt
idea would say, so what would
Gram and Schmidt say?
They'd say, well, we
only have one column,
and all we would have
to do is normalize it
So Gram-Schmidt would produce
the normalized thing --
times square root of 2.
That would be the q, and
this would be the r, 1 by 1,
in Gram Schmidt.
OK, but here's the point, that
the qr algorithm in MATLAB,
which no longer uses
the Gram-Schmidt idea,
instead uses a Householder idea,
and one nice thing about this
is that it produces not just
this column, but another one,
it produces a column for the
-- it completes the basis
to a full orthonormal basis.
So it finds a second vector.
So ordinary
Gram-Schmidt just had
one column times one number.
What qr actually does is it
ends up with two columns.
And well, everybody can see
what's the other column --
that has length 1, of course,
and is orthogonal to the first
column.
And now, that is
multiplied by 0.
So this is what qr does.
We have this 2 by 1 matrix,
it produces a 2 by 2 times a 2
by 1.
And you might say, it
was wasting its time,
to find this part, because
it's multiplied by 0,
but what are we learning
from the vector?
From this [1, 1] vector or
1 over square root of 2,
1 over square root of 2 vector?
What good can that do us?
It's the null space of
B. So B was 1, minus 1,
So let me just -- so that's
the connection with null space
of B. If I look at vectors
-- there's my matrix B,
and if I'm solving B*u equal
d, if I'm solving B*u equal d,
then u is u_particular
and u null space,
and if I want u null space, then
that's where this -- and these,
whatever extra columns, this
might be p columns and then
this would be n minus p columns,
that's what that's good for.
And of course that
column tells me
about the null space
which, for this matrix,
is one-dimensional
and easy to find, OK.
So that may be just to, so you
know the difference between
Gram-Schmidt's qr
which stops with --
if you had one column
you end with one column,
and the MATLAB Householder
qr which finds a full square
matrix.
OK, just good to know and
here we've found a use for it.
OK.
So then, the algorithm
that I gave last time --
and I'll give the
code in the notes --
goes through the steps of
finding a u_particular,
and actually, the u_particular
that it would find happens
to be -- [3, minus 3] happens
to be the actual winner.
And therefore, the u null space
that that algorithm would find
-- if I went through
all the steps,
you would see that because I'm
in this special case of b being
0 and so on,
that the vector that
it would choose --
this is the basis
for the null space,
but it would choose 0 of that
basis vector and would come up
with that answer.
OK so that's what the
algorithm from last time
would have done to this problem.
I also, over the weekend,
thought OK, if it's all true,
I should be able to
use my first method.
The large alpha method
and just find the answer
to the original problem and
let alpha go to infinity.
Are you willing to do that?
That might take a
little more calculation,
but let me try that.
I'm hoping, you know, that
it approaches this answer.
This is the answer
I'm looking for.
OK so, do your mind just
-- suppose I had to do that
minimization.
Again, now I'm not using
the null space method,
so I'm not reducing, I'm not
getting u_2 out of the problem.
I'm doing the minimum as it
stands, and so what do I get?
Well, I've got two
variables u_1 and u_2.
So I take the derivatives
with respect u_1 --
I'm minimizing --
everybody, when I point,
I'm pointing at that top line.
So it's 2*u_1, and
what do I have here?
2*alpha u_1 minus u_2
minus 6 equaling 0.
Is that -- did I take the
u_1 derivative correctly?
Now if I take the u_2
derivative I get two u_2's.
And now, the chain rule is
going to give me a minus sign,
so it would be a minus 2*alpha
u_1 minus u_2 minus 6 equals 0.
So those two equations
will determine u_1 and u_2
for a finite alpha.
And then I'll let alpha head to
infinity and see what happens.
OK, first I'll
multiply by a half
and get rid of those
useless 2's, and then
solve this equation.
OK, so what do I have here?
I've got a matrix -- u_1 is
multiplying 1 plus alpha,
u_2 has a minus alpha.
In this line, u_1 has a minus
alpha, u_1 has a 1 minus,
minus, plus alpha, am I right?
Times [u 1, u 2] equals --
what's my right-hand side?
I guess the right-hand
side has alphas in it.
6*alpha and minus
6*alpha, I think.
OK.
two equations, two unknowns.
These are the normal equation
for this problem, written out
explicitly.
And probably I can
find the solution
and let alpha go to infinity.
You could say,
what are you doing,
Professor Strang, this
elementary calculation?
But there is something sort
of satisfying about seeing
a small example actually work.
At least to me.
OK, so how do I solve
those equations?
Well, good question.
Should I -- with
a 2 by 2 matrix,
can I do the unforgivable and
actually find its inverse?
I mean, it's like not allowed
in true linear algebra
to find the inverse, but
maybe we could do it here.
So [u 1, u 2] is going to be
the inverse matrix, which is --
so my little recipe for finding
inverses is take the entries,
this entry goes up is up here,
that entry goes down there --
well, you couldn't
see the difference --
this entry stays stays in
place, those change sign,
and then I have to divide
by the determinant.
So what was the
determinant of this?
1 plus 2*alpha plus alpha
squared minus alpha squared,
I get 1 plus 2 alpha.
And that's the inverse matrix
now that's multiplying 6*alpha
and minus 6*alpha, OK.
And if I can do that
multiplication, I have -- well,
there's this factor 1
over 1 plus 2*alpha,
and what do I have?
6*alpha, 6 alpha squared,
minus 6 alpha squared,
I think 6*alpha?
6 alpha squared, minus 6*alpha
squared plus -- minus 6 alpha,
I think it's that,
minus 6*alpha.
And, ready for the great moment?
Let alpha go to infinity,
and what do I get?
As alpha goes to infinity,
the 1 becomes insignificant,
the alpha cancels the alpha,
so that approaches [3, -3].
So there you see the large
alpha method in practice.
OK.
And you see what -- well,
there's something quite
important here.
Something quite important,
and it's connected
with the pseudoinverse.
The pseudoinverse -- so now,
I want to, we got this answer.
And what I want to say is that
the alpha, the limiting alpha
system, has produced
this pseudoinverse.
So now I have to tell you
about the pseudoinverse
and what it means.
And basically, the essential
thing that it means
is, the pseudoinverse
gives the solution u which
has no null space component.
That's what the
pseudoinverse is about.
I'll draw a picture to
say what I'm saying.
But it's this fact that
means that this part,
which was this number,
is the output --
this is the pseudoinverse
of B applied to [6, 6].
You see the point?
B hasn't got an inverse.
B is 1, minus 1.
It's a rectangular matrix.
And it's not invertible
in the normal sense.
I can't find a
two-sided inverse;
a B inverse doesn't exist.
But a pseudoinverse counts.
So, just to give a MATLAB -- as
long as I've written a MATLAB
command here, why don't I
write the other MATLAB command?
u is the pseudoinverse -- you
remember that pseudo starts
with a letter p, so P-I-N-V
-- of B multiplying d.
That's what we
got automatically.
And it's what we get --
and the reason we got
the pseudoinverse.
So let me just say
what was special here.
What was special that
produced this pseudoinverse --
that I'm going to
speak about more --
was this choice A equal
the identity and b equal 0,
the fact that we just put the
norm of u squared there --
well, the idea is this
produces the pseudoinverse.
And if you like -- so, can I
say a little more about this
pseudoinverse before drawing
the picture that shows what
it's about?
So I took this thing and
let alpha go to infinity.
OK, so I could equally well
have divided it by alpha,
the whole -- if I divide
the whole thing by alpha,
that won't change the minimizer;
certainly the same u's will
win.
And now I see one
over alpha going to 0.
And that's where the
pseudoinverse is usually seen.
We take the given problem,
which does not completely
determine u_1 and
u_2, and we throw
in a small amount
of norm u squared,
and find the minimum
for that, right.
So yeah.
Let me say it, somehow.
I take the B transpose B
plus the 1 over alpha I --
now alpha is still going to
infinity in this lecture,
so 1 over alpha, the whole
thing is headed for 0 --
times the norm of u square.
This is the u_1 squared
plus u_2 squared.
OK.
And that inverse, that quantity
inverse approaches the -- well,
once I -- I'm not giving
the complete formula,
but that's is what entering
here and it leads to --
may I see the vague word leads
toward the pseudoinverse B
plus.
Yeah.
And I'll do better with that.
OK, I want to go
on to the picture.
OK, so right.
Do you know the most important
picture of linear algebra?
The whole picture what a
matrix is actually doing?
Here we have a great example
to draw that picture.
So here's the picture
that 18.06 is --
it's at the center of 18.06.
For our 2 by 1 matrix.
So this is our matrix
is B equals 1, minus 1.
This is the picture
for that matrix.
OK, so that matrix
has a row space.
The row space is the
set of all vectors that
are a combinations of the rows.
But there's only one row, so
the row space is only a line.
I guess it's probably that line.
So the row space
of B, of my matrix,
is all multiples of [1, -1].
So it's a line.
Let's put the zero point in.
OK, then the matrix
also has a null space.
The null space as the side
of solutions to B*x equals 0.
It's a line, and in fact
it's a perpendicular line.
So this is the null space
of B, and it contains all --
what does it contain?
All the solutions to B*u
equals 0 which, in this case,
are all multiples of [1, 1].
And just to come back
to my early comment,
that's what the qr, the extra
half of the qr algorithm
is telling us; it's giving
us a beautiful basis
for the null space.
And so the key point is that
the null space is always
perpendicular to the row space,
which of course we see here.
This z is what we had to
compute when there were
p components and not just one.
And now, where is -- let's
see, what else goes into this
picture?
Where are the solutions to
my equation B*u equal d?
So my equation was -- my
equation was u_1 minus u_2
equal a particular number, 6,
and where are the solutions
to u_1 minus u_2 equals 6?
OK, so now I want to draw all
the -- Where are all the --
so this is the u1, u2 plane?
OK, so one solution is
take c equal to 3. [3, -3],
the combination [3, -3],
which is right there,
is my particular solution, so
u_particular, or u row space,
is [3, -3].
That solves the equation,
and it lies in the row space.
And now, if you
understand the whole point
of linear equations, where
are the rest of the solutions?
How do I draw the
rest of the solutions?
Well, to a particular solution I
add on any null space solution.
The null space
solutions go this way.
So I add on -- so this is my
whole line of all solutions,
so this is the line
of all solutions.
And now, the key question is,
which solution is the smallest?
When -- so this is the
idea this pseudoinverse.
When there are many solutions,
pick the smallest one,
pick the shortest one, it's
the most stable somehow.
It's the natural one.
And which one is it?
OK which -- so
here is the origin.
What point on that line
is closest to the origin?
What point minimizes u_1
square plus u_2 square?
Everybody can see.
This guy, that minimi--
so the pseudoinverse says,
wait a minute, when you've
got a whole line of solutions,
just tell me a good one.
Tell me the special one.
And the special one is
the one in the row space.
And that's the one that
the pseudoinverse picks.
So the pseudoinverse of a matrix
-- so the general rule is,
and part of the lecture
was the fact that,
as alpha goes to
infinity in this problem,
the pseudoinverse will do it.
Or I could say, just directly,
what does the pseudoinverse do?
The pseudoinverse -- so B plus,
the pseudoinverse, chooses,
it chooses u_p, if you like,
u_p -- that's the B plus,
that multiplies -- the solution
-- I can't say B inverse d.
Everybody knows my
equation is B*u equal d.
So this is my
equation, B*u equal d.
And my particular solution,
my pseudo-solution, my best
solution, is going
to be B plus d,
and it's going to
be in the row space,
because it's the
smallest solution.
So if you meet the
idea of pseudoinverses,
now you know what
it's talking about.
Because we don't
have a true inverse,
we have a whole line of a
solutions, we want to pick one,
and the pseudoinverse
picks this one.
It's the one in the row
space, and it's the shortest,
because these are orthogonal.
Because these are orthogonal
-- u is u_p plus u_n,
and because those
are orthogonal,
the length of u
squared, by Pythagoras,
is the length of u_p squared
plus the length of u_n squared.
And which one is shortest?
The one that has no u_n.
That orthogonal
component might as well
be 0 if you want the shortest.
So all solutions have
this, and this is
the length of the shortest one.
OK.
So that tells you what
the pseudoinverse is.
At least it tells you what
it is for a 1 by 2 matrix.
As long as I'm trying to
speak about the pseudoinverse,
let me complete this thought.
But you saw the idea,
that the thought was --
there are there two
ways to get it, again.
The null space method
that goes for it directly,
or the big alpha method that
we checked actually works.
So that was the point
of this board here.
That the big alpha method, also
produces, in the limit as alpha
goes to infinity, u_p.
And there's a little
-- it doesn't have --
if alpha was a 1,000, I wouldn't
get exactly the right answer,
because this would be
2,001 in the denominator.
But as 1,000 becomes a million
and alpha goes to infinity,
I guess the exact one.
OK, so here I was going
to draw the picture,
so if I draw row space -- can I
imagine this is the row space,
whose dimension is the
rank of the matrix.
Perpendicular to it is the
null space whose dimension is
the rest -- the rank, that was
the rank that I always call r,
then this will have the
dimension n minus r,
the number of --
this is exactly,
these are the two things
that MATLAB found here.
These were the r vectors in the
row space, turned into columns,
and these were the n minus r
-- but that was only one --
vectors in the null space.
So normally, we're up in n
dimensions, not just two.
With two dimensions, I just
had lines; in n dimensions
I have an r-dimensional
subspace perpendicular
to an n minus r
dimensional subspace.
And now B. What does B do?
OK.
So suppose I take a vector
u_n in the null space
o B. Then B takes it to 0.
So can I just draw
that with an arrow?
This'll be 0.
B*u_n is 0, that's
the whole idea.
OK.
But a vector in a row
space is not taken to 0.
B will take that --- dot
dot dot dot -- into the --
I better draw here -- the
column space of B. OK.
Which I'm drawing as a subspace
whose dimension is also,
is this same rank r, that's
the great fact about matrices,
that the number of
independent rows
equals the number of
independent columns.
So this guy heads off
to some B u row space.
OK.
And if I've complete the
picture, as I really should,
there's another
subspace over here,
which happened to be the zero
subspace in this example,
but usually it's here.
It's the null space
of B transpose.
In that example, B
transpose was [1, -1]
and its column was independent,
so there was no null space.
So I had a simple
picture, and that's
why I wanted to draw you
a bigger picture with it.
It's dimension will be,
well, not n minus r,
but if B is m by
n, let's say, then
it turns out that
this null space will
have dimension m minus r.
No problem.
OK.
Now, in the last
three minutes, I
want to draw the pseudoinverse.
So what I'm saying is
that every matrix B,
every rectangular
or square matrix B,
has these four spaces.
Four fundamental subspaces
they've come to be called.
OK and the null space is the
vectors which B takes to 0.
B takes any vector
into its column space.
So now let me just draw what
happens to u equal u null
space plus u row space.
So this was a guy
in the row space.
If I -- B, what will B do
when multiplies this vector?
This vector has a part
that's in the null space,
and a part that's
in the row space.
But when I multiply by B,
what happens to this part?
Gone.
When I multiply that
by B, where does it go?
There.
So this, all these guys
feed into that same point.
B*u is also going there.
That's why it's not invertible.
Of course.
Here, I guess --
yeah, here I -- sorry.
Yeah.
This was the null space of
B. I didn't write in what
it was the null space of.
OK.
So the matrix couldn't be
invertible, and actually,
because it has a null space,
and they all send those --
so what is the
pseudoinverse, finally?
Finally, last moment, the
pseudoinverse is the matrix --
it's like an inverse matrix
that comes backwards, right?
It reverses what B does.
What it cannot do is reverse
stuff that's appeared at 0.
No matrix could send
0 back to u_n right?
If i multiply by
the zero vector,
I'm only going to
get the zero vector.
So the pseudoinverse has to --
what it can do is it can send
this stuff back to this.
This is what the
pseudoinverse does.
If I had a different color
chalk I would use it now.
But let use two
arrows or even three.
This is what the
pseudoinverse does.
It takes the column space and
sends it back to the row space.
And because these have the same
dimension r -- the point is,
inside B is this r by
r matrix that's cool.
It's totally invertible.
And B plus inverts it.
So from row space
to column space
goes B; from column
space back to row space
comes the pseudoinverse, but I
can't call it a genuine inverse
because all this stuff,
including 0, the best I can do
is send those all back to 0.
There.
Now I've really wiped
out that figure.
But I'll put the
three arrows there
that makes it crystal clear.
So this, those three
arrows are indicating
what the pseudoinverse does.
It takes the column space -- Its
column space is the row space.
The column space of B plus
is the row space of B.
You know, sort of, in these
two spaces, that's where
the pseudoinverse is alive.
And B kills the null space and
B plus kills the null space --
the other null space.
The null space of B transpose.
Anyway, that pseudoinverse is at
the center of the whole theory
here.
You know, when I take out
books from the library
about regularizing
least squares,
they begin by explaining
the pseudoinverse.
Which, as we've seen, arises
as alpha goes to infinity
or 0, whichever end we're at.
And what I have
still to do next time
is, what happens if
I'm not prepared to go
all the way to
the pseudoinverse,
because it blows up on me,
and I want a finite alpha,
what should that alpha be?
And that alpha will be
determined by, as I said,
somehow by the noise
level in the system.
Right.
And just to emphasize another
example that I'll probably
mention, you know,
CT scans, MRI,
all those things that
are trying to reconstruct
the results from limited number
of measurements, measurements
that are not really enough
to perfect reconstruction,
so this is the theory of
imperfect reconstruction,
if I can invent an
expression, having
met perfect reconstruction
in the world of wavelets
and signal processing,
this is the subject
of imperfect
reconstruction and I'll
hope to do justice
to it on Wednesday.
OK.
Thank you.